barbie has got a foothold on the berlin
property market but only until the end
of august tickets to enter the mobile
mansion of the world's most famous dog
cost 12 euros inside there are a number
of diversions visitors can make virtual
cupcakes
check out the state-of-the-art make-up
range or admire Barbie's expansive
wardrobe
they're also welcome to spend their
money in the barbie boutique so what do
the customers think it's wonderful it's
beautiful and pink and big like a
child's dream come true kid it's a bit
too colorful for some Barbie's
Dreamhouse feels more like a nightmare
gender studies researchers Stevie shmita
has been investigating attitudes towards
Barbie Barbie's been enormously
successful because she represents
something unattainable she's tall blond
and blue-eyed a stereotype of the
unachievable female ideal barbie
expresses the idea that you always have
to make yourself beautiful and the
beauty means power and of course that's
wrong
what does 'taking talk shows Barbie
along with her unrealistic bodily
proportions has long been a
controversial figure the world's
best-selling Donnell first appeared in
the market in 1959 she's become world
renowned
Betina Dorfman from Dusseldorf owns
15,000 Barbies a world record 19 years
ago she decided to get some of her old
dolls repaired for her daughter when she
failed to find anyone up to the task
she started restoring Barbies herself
her collection began to grow I almost
always had Barbie with me when I was a
child and that's what makes it all so
much fun for me to relive that period
she always reflects the spirit of the
age and she's slightly ahead of her time
Falls
Bettina Dorfman also owns the oldest
Barbie on the planet worth about eight
thousand euros Ruth handler founder of
US toy company Mattel based barbie on
the design of shop mannequins
two years later ken arrived on the scene
Barbie's image was beginning to change
some famous names have designed clothes
for Barbie the diminutive diva has
always been a trendsetter here we have
the trends of the 1960s you've got their
tight skirts the covered knees and
especially this bouffant hairstyle back
then every woman sported this style
Bettina Dorfman has turned her hobby
into a profession she curates exhibits
like this one in bag common in northern
Germany devoted to fashion and glamour
various Barbies are on display from all
different races and even special
editions like film stars Audrey Hepburn
and Marilyn Monroe barbie has many faces
including the presidential candidate
the astronaut or the soldier Betina
Dorfman thinks criticism is misplaced by
Bob Ezrin bobby is beautiful
she has ideal proportions if I take off
her clothes she's just an object then
she looks like a seamstresses mannequin
and children know that people don't love
Barbie they love the image and
accessories connected to and Barbies
glamour is attracting people to the
dream house in Berlin that's why you'll
be hard-pressed to find a Barbie in a
mechanic's overalls and the visitors
like what they see the organizers are
expecting 10,000 per week this dream
house
the dream house represents the pink off'
ocation that we're currently
experiencing girls are being raised to
identify with pink and boys with blue
unfortunately Barbie tells girls to be
cute and sweet they're supposed to
become supermodels great but the dream
house does also show that pink doesn't
have to be just for girls the exhibit
was designed by a man
you